[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans
audition publique sur la chaîne
parlementaire premier conseil des
ministres aujourd'hui du premier
gouvernement de macron 2 la priorité
affichée c'est le pouvoir d'achat mais
la crise la première crise à gérer eh
bien elle est politique c'est le cas le
dossier damien abad jusqu'à nouvel ordre
il reste ministre aujourd'hui à trois
semaines du premier tour des
législatives notre invité est lent
jacomelli bonjour à vous bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes porte parole
du rassemblement national candidats à
ces législatives dans la 8e
circonscription de la moselle à trois
semaines du scrutin laurent jacot bélie
la stratégie de marine le pen interroge
pourquoi anticiper la défaite est-ce
pour contredire jean luc mélenchon qui
se pose en opposant numéro 1 surtout
depuis qu'il a eu ni la gauche avec la
vue baisse la nuque ce n'est ce pas
prendre leur et le risque de démobiliser
vos troupes et d'ailleurs fait vous
vraiment campagne on vous entend très
peu toutes ces questions c'est yves
thréard qui voulaient posera tout à
l'heure vincent roux pour la question
d'actu ce sera dans un quart d'heure et
bien sûr notre duo brigitte boucher
thème traduit pour les questions cribles
mais d'abord si vous voulez bien
ensemble un retour sur la composition du
gouvernement il n'y a pas mal à dire on
va commencer par le dossier damien abad
damien bad nommé vendredi ministre des
solidarités et du handicap il est
également candidat d'ailleurs aux
législatives dans l'ain et il fait face
à des accusations de violence sexuelle
qui remonte à plusieurs années on y
reviendra si vous voulez dans dans le
détail il
il repousse ses accusations il les
récuse avec force avec vivacité et il ya
une heure il a pris la parole devant la
mairie de la sinne d'une des villes sa
circonscription de l'ain écoutez cet
extrait
art
n'a pas l'extrait mais je vais vous lire
d'accord c'est
qu'est ce qu'il a dit il a dit je
conteste les accusations à mon encontre
avec la plus grande des fermetés toutes
les relations sexuelles que j'ai pu
avoir dans ma vie a toujours était
mutuellement consenti à la question d'un
journaliste allez vous démissionner un
homme innocent doit-il démissionner je
ne crois pas lent jacobellis
s'agit-il d'une bonne ou d'une mauvaise
polémique écoutez en tout cas c'est une
polémique qui pose question
effectivement parce que le président de
la république et a mis beaucoup de temps
à choisir sa première ministre l'
annonce du gouvernement on l'a bien vu
l' ami aussi beaucoup de temps donc on
pouvait imaginer que c'était une
sélection rigoureuse que le président de
la république voulait être sûr que ce
qui allait mener la politique du
gouvernement et donc diriger la france
dans les années qui viennent soit des
gens performants au dessus de tout
soupçon et on voit que l' enquête a été
quand même assez défaillante moi je ne
sais pas si monsieur la bad est coupable
ou pas mais ce que je sais c'est qu'on
nous refait le coup du on savait mais on
ne disait rien c'est ce qui sort à peu
près de des témoignages de chez les
républicains qu'on ne peut pas imaginer
que le président de la république madame
ben n'était pas au courant non vous
rappelleront non mais c'est intéressant
parce que effectivement il ya berne par
dont elle a pris la parole précisément
pour dire quand elle a été interrogée
sur ce dossier je n'étais pas au courant
est ce que vous mettez en doute sa
sincérité
t dit comme ça je vais peut-être avoir
l'air un peu un peu tranchée mais oui
parce que apparemment les témoignages
des anciens collègues de monsieur abad
chez les républicains sont unanimes et
disent oui on avait entendu parler de
choses on avait eu des remontées on
n'avait pas fait d' enquête alors ça
pose deux questions pourquoi les
républicains n'avaient pas fait d'
enquête pourquoi est-ce que la sphère
sort maintenant donc on sent bien une
histoire de vengeance et de guéguerre
entre deux équipes qui se rêve un jeu
qui se vend les républicains
probablement du gouvernement qui pour
vous c'est audi lancera la préférence
yeux abad mais peu importe mais surtout
pourquoi madame borne n'a pas fait une
enquête ça fait quand même beaucoup on
en est au 13e ou 14e mises en examen
dans ce gouvernement si on reprend le
quinquennat précédent il ya eu beaucoup
d'histoires d'agression sexuelle je vais
pas revenir sur les personnes qui ont
fait l'objet parce que présomption
d'innocence mais certains sont ministre
ça fait quand même beaucoup ça leur a
demandé au président de la république
qui avait fait
d'avoir tout reprendre vous faites
allusion en particulier
au
rappel que là et que la question a été
classée sans suite en ce qui concerne
une des affaires de gérald darmanin pour
la seconde est bien l'affairé close et
il n'a pas été mise en examen soit six
pour la précision c'est important vous
avez un jour mais elisabeth bornes si
elle n'était pas au courant elle ne
pouvait pas lancer une enquête et
aujourd'hui ce que nous dit olivier
grégoire porte-parole du gouvernement
est intéressant parce qu'elle a été très
clair tout les rangs zéro pour les
délinquants sexuels et écoute totale des
victimes présumées elles doivent porter
plainte aujourd'hui le gouvernement
comment dirais-je encourage vivement
toutes les femmes à porter plainte et
c'est devant la justice que doivent se
régler ses achats et du bas dans
l'opinion publique celle là il n'y a pas
de plaintes dans cet alizé mais deux
matches soit gouvernement dans c'est un
symbole ouais quand on veut faire de la
condition de la femme de la protection
de la femme de la lutte contre les
comportements
d'agression sexuelle il faut montrer
l'exemple et je ne peux pas croire que
ce que booth beaucoup savaient dans le
milieu politique sur des accusations
fondées ou infondées d'ailleurs sur
monsieur abad qu'on ne pouvait pas le
savoir au gouvernement il ya un principe
de précaution de dire eh ben on va faire
une enquête rigoureuse et puis quand on
aura une conclusion qu on aura entendu
monsieur abadennoù sera convaincu de son
innocence on le nommera ministre le
faire avant et faire l'enquète après ça
me paraît mettre les choses dans un
ordre qui n'est pas le bon et ça me
parait envoyé à très mal un signal elle
d'impréparation demande d'étude et de
manque de professionnalisme dans
l'élaboration du gouvernement elle
conséquences à en tirer le gouvernement
alors maintenant ils sont dans une
position bien difficile c est maintenant
qu il est nommé lui demander de rentrer
chez lui alors qu'il est ministre sans
avoir de preuves supplémentaires c'est
un peu c'est un peu délicat il aurait
fallu agir avant vous savez il ya
bientôt des élections les gens qui ne
doit pas démissionner pour vous c'est
trop tard moi je pense que ludo lui-même
il devrait démissionner oui voilà
le gouvernement doit le pousser à
démissionner ce serait habile de voir
avec lui s'ils ne pourraient pas se
mettre en retrait en effet une fois le
démer sauf s'il ya des preuves concrètes
de son innocence je le rappelle mais une
fois encore comme d'autres ministres ont
déjà leur peut-être le plus simple
aurait été de ne pas le nommer sur le
plan des principes qu'est-ce qu'on fait
la présomption d'innocence dans ce clip
d'affaires vous avez raison la
présomption d'innocence s'applique à
tous y compris aux ministres le plus
simple je le répète aurait été vu les
d'ouvrir alors aujourd'hui de ne pas le
nommer min alors maintenant maintenant
raisonnons avec ce qu'est ce qu'on a à
ses choix qu'est-ce qu'on fait la
présomption d'innocence s'agissait là
mais abad elle s'appelle c'est parce que
vous le dites y avait des rumeurs il n'y
a pas de fumée sans feu s'agira là je ne
suis pas allé jusqu'à n'y a pas de fumée
sans feu j'ai dit on il y avait des
choses qui circulait c'est ce que dit
d'ailleurs monsieur jacob je crois mais
sa femme n'est pas l'alternance et il
n'y aurait pas dans le monde emmanuel
macron dit d'accord madame baume sont
dus entre de parler il ya ces ministres
venus des républicains au sein du
gouvernement actuel pour qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas ne pas savoir c'est ce que
vous dit ça paraît suspect et si c'est
le cas franchement c'est inquiétant donc
la question la présemption d'innocence
et même plus ce sujet que vous dites oui
j'ai c'est la négligence et la
négligence et l'imprudence vêtements
parmi les ministres qui ont été nommés
il ya ce cas qui posent problème pour
une question de symbole pour une
question de lutte contre les agressions
sexuelles contre les femmes il ya doute
ministre qui porte question on a quand
même aujourd'hui un ministre indigéniste
mais c'est quand même grave la lame ne
mettait pas
osé dans mon panier je sens votre
impatience d'en parler mais c'est une
question importante
c'est un débat très vite donc je vous
repose la question par exemple jean luc
mélenchon le président de la nuque tu
dis clairement lui est bien lorsqu il y
à un arbitrage à faire entre la
présomption d'innocence et des
accusations qui circule même si un pas
de deux décisions de justice
donc des femmes qui accusent un
responsable public eh bien il faut
privilégier la parole de l'accusation
aux dépens de la présomption d'innocence
un sujet délicat quels sujets délicats
et j'y vois un bémol j'y vois un bémol
c'est qu'il ne faut pas que ces
accusations servent d'armes politique
c'est à dire que
si l'on n'a pas de preuves il est
difficile de démettre quelqu'un du jour
au lendemain en revanche la parole des
femmes doit primer oui en effet parce
que sinon elles ne seront plus portés
plein de demain et donc je l'aurais pas
si vous êtes premier ministre d'un
gouvernement rassemblement national que
vous l'avez un ministre qu'il ne fait
pas l'objet d'une plainte en justice et
sur lequel circulent des accusations qui
sont reçus par une association de femmes
est ce que vous le démété au nom de la
supériorité de la parole de la femme sur
la présomption d'innocence d'abord ne
pas le nommer et puis s'il est nommé
effectivement oui prendre une mesure
salutaire un symbole très fort faire une
enquête approfondie et le renommer
ministre dès qu'on est tranquille dès qu
on dansera à nos principes de précaution
là le principe de près la mission
évidemment alors on avant le répète j'ai
contourné le fait de la condition de la
femme et de la protection des femmes
contre les agressions sexuelles une
priorité alors pap ndiaye vous y êtes
vous allé tout seul parce que le sujet
vous brûle les lèvres j'ai l'impression
parce que je vais me nommé vendredi
ministre de l'éducation nationale
elisabeth borne à deux reprises a salué
ce symbole de la méritocratie
républicaine c'est un homme c'est un
écrivain c'est un professeur
d'université un intellectuel qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur la condition
noire notamment aux états unis et il
était président du musée de
l'immigration c'est un homme très
respecté par les milieux universitaires
vous avez dit marine le pen tout de
suite après la nomination
elle a dégainé si je peux dire un tweet
assez furieux en dénonçant la nomination
d'un indigéniste au coeur du pouvoir
vous maintenez l'accusation d' habillage
oui bien sûr je ne renie pas
l'intelligence et le parcours
universitaire de monsieur papa
il est sûrement très brillant en
revanche je retiens de son parcours
d'autres choses qui me laisse
interrogatif sur le fait qu'il soit
opportun de le nommer ministre de
l'éducation nationale quand on a
participé à des réunions de parole non
blanches c'est inquiétant quand c'était
en 2016 quand en 2017 dans le journal le
monde on disait qu'il il y avait un
racisme structurel en france quand on
passe son temps notamment au sein de
l'association le cran à définir les gens
en fonction de leur couleur de peau est
ce que vous croyez qu'on peut confier le
ministère de l'éducation nationale à
quelqu'un comme ça parce que ça n'allait
pas petite nuance parce qu'effectivement
il a parlé de racisme structurel mais il
a immédiatement ajouté qu'il n'y avait
pas de racisme d'état en france il n'y a
pas
at il dit une politique qui est basé sur
un racisme systémique elle a précisé oui
hélas il a aussi précisé dans une
interview radiophonique qu'il n'y en a
pas racisme de la police vous savez
aujourd'hui notre france elle est
divisée comme jamais aujourd'hui il y a
des gens qui en france ne se sentent pas
à l'aise voire même n'aime pas la france
l'ancien ministre monsieur coulon de
l'intérieur disait que on vivrait côte à
côte on risque demain de vivre face à
face est ce que vous croyez vraiment que
m
ce monsieur comme ministre de
l'éducation monsieur pape ndiaye j'ai
dit tout à l'heure si vous en faites pas
moi je ne suis pas sectaire
contrairement à lui apparemment ça ne va
pas arranger les choses sacrées sacré
sacré dès le départ la notion de race
entre guillemets de couleur de peau
comme déterminant essentiel c'est pas ça
la république française
certains disent il faut y sont
importants elisabeth bande l'a dit faut
être fier que effectivement un ministre
de couleur ministre c'est la première
fois qu'un ministre noire accède à des
responsabilités aussi importantes ça
vous inquiète plus les chaluts des
ministres guy qu'est laurent front
ministère l'éducation mieux mais vous
c'est du racisme caractérisée parce que
monsieur une vieille est en partie
d'origine sénégalaise c'est de la
connerie humaine voilà ce qu'a dit
laurent berger ce matin et pour pour
apprécier vous savez actions du
rassemblement national est très claire
de la connerie humaine aucun rassise
racice aucun racisme n'est supérieur aux
autres le racisme est condamnable en
général qu'ils soient contre les gens de
couleur qui soit contre les blancs vous
savez la france c'est bien sûr la
métropole c'est sont aussi les
territoires ultramarins la france n'est
pas une couleur sur votre citoyenneté
une nation et définir les gens par leur
couleur ce que fait monsieur pape ndiaye
et je le cite ça me paraît contraire à
nos principes républicains et on a
l'impression que c'est une course à
l'échalote que monsieur macron veut
renvoyer l'ascenseur en fait à monsieur
mélenchon qui l'a fait élire en lui
faisant une prise de guerre et leurs
valises en vous voyez monsieur mélenchon
je suis comme vous moi aussi je crois
qu'il n'y a pas d'arrêt temps
oui c'est un coup mais à force de coups
à force de chercher des électeurs a
ciblé à force de vouloir piquer des gens
dans le camp adverse on en oublie
l'intérêt général on en oublie la bonne
marche de la nation on en oublie les
objectifs pour notre pays à 5 10 15 ou
20 ans il a 5 ou au lieu d'attendre et
que je ne lui accordait pas le bénéfice
du doute à pap ndiaye en dix ans dont je
rassure pièce sa politique c'est ça qui
est le plus important je serai le plus
heureux des hommes s'il y avait une
agréable surprise or je vois ce qu'il a
écrit je vois ce qu'il a fait je vois
les incendies linda lesquels il a milité
et traîtresse honnêtement cela reste
inquiétant
monsieur mélenchon rêve d'être premier
ministre il ne le sera jamais et
d'ailleurs il n'a pas besoin de l'être
puisque le gouvernement finalement lui
fait déjà plaisir on y reviendra tout à
l'heure une question avant vincent
rumba père est au psg
c'est une bonne nouvelle il ya quelqu'un
de talent qui restent en france est
toujours une bonne nouvelle
emmanuel macron at il dit
est intervenu pour qu'il reste au psg
voilà une belle action d' emmanuel
macron vous élever sa politique à
l'égard des maps et je sais pas si c'est
le rôle du président de la république
mais vous savez moi d'une manière
générale quand les talents restent en
france quand les talents servent à créer
de la richesse créée de la joie en
l'occurrence c'est une bonne chose vous
savez nous sommes d'ailleurs voulu
permettrez de ne pas payer mais j'ai
aucun impôt oui de tout l'argent qu'ils
gagnent pas beaucoup de talent talent il
n'y a pas qu'un seul talent grâce à vous
parce qu'elle atteint de trois ans n'a
pas pu échapper c'est il ya beaucoup de
talent et nous on veut effectivement
avec marine le pen et jordan bardella
que tous les jeunes de moins de 8 ans je
voulais pas ouvrir ce chapitre mais je
le signale au passage moi je vais vous
dire à quel point ne vais pas dans la
mission de revenus pour les garder sur
le territoire parce que la france est
riche de tous ces jeunes qui veulent
s'investir en elle-même sahara dont
l'usure vous voyez il est resté bonjour
vincent où vous êtes entier du figaro
live alors j'ai bien introduit votre
question alesi vincent
bonsoir va écouter on va rester sur les
jeunes de moins de 30 ans et sur les
joueurs du psg bonsoir lors laurent
jacoby on se souvient dix jours
justement le milieu de terrain du psg
idriss guèye a déclaré forfait lors de
la 37e journée de ligue 1 face à
montpellier alors il n'a pas donné de la
raison officielle sauf que c'était des
raisons personnelles mais il ya une
polémique car il paraît il apparaît que
c'est en raison d'un malaise d'un refus
de jouer le jour de l'engagement delà du
football professionnel français contre
l'homophobie alors est ce que vous êtes
de ceux qui respectent sa liberté de
conscience dans ce cas là ou bien ce que
vous êtes de ceux qui pensent comme
valérie pécresse notamment qu'il faut
condamner et le condamner pour cet acte
mais je pense que c'est tactile est
condamnable il est condamnable parce
qu'il met au ban de la société
je crois un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes qui ont
qu'ils sont homosexuels et que ce n'est
pas normal dans notre société vous savez
les reculs religieux en france
aujourd'hui sont de plus en plus
nombreux l'égalité hommes femmes battues
en brèche avec l'arrivée du burkini dans
les piscines à grenoble aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens de
confession juive ou homosexuels sont
chassés de certaines banlieues
communautariser parce que il y aurait
une vision radicale de l'islam il faut
le dire tout cela n'est pas acceptable
la france c'est pas ça la france c'est
la tolérance en france un homme peut
aimer un homme une femme peut aimer une
femme une femme est l'égal de l'homme ce
sont des principes sur lesquels nous ne
devrions pas transiger moi j'aimerais
poser d'ailleurs l'art est la question à
monsieur eric piolle qui doit être un
peu
divisée entre la défense de deux
minorités entre guillemets quand il voit
de tels propos sur les homosexuels est
ce que ça ne met pas un peu mal à l'aise
de céder aux demandes de l'islam
rigoriste façon vous avez votre réponse
je ne comprends pas quel est le lien
entre eric piolle
moi je le comprends très bien joué les
six et ben je vais vous le dire c'est à
la fois condamné mais je vais vous
expliquer cette affaire aujourd'hui en
france on en arrive à de tels
comportements parce que petit à petit
certains élus certains philosophes
certains penseurs ont reculé devant les
dites demande d'un islam politique
radicale qui fait que les homosexuels
devraient être au ban de la société que
les femmes ne sont pas légales de
l'homme et qu'elle devrait se cacher et
donc je mets en cause très clairement un
certain nombre de politiciens qui part
communautarisme on laisser de tels
comportements se propage mans c'est on a
compris le raisonnement gros seins
vincent pour en arriver là en effet
c'est pas vous cette semaine qui aviez
posé la question sur le burqini pourtant
mais merci à vous en tout cas vincent
je vous présente brigitte busch et m30
mais ils vont me poser des questions
très précises sur le programmes des
manuels macro est le vôtre bonsoir leurs
engins kabylie alors le gouvernement
veut présenter son paquet pouvoir
d'achat ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative avec de nombreuses mesures
en faveur du pouvoir d'achat avant les
législatives à ce que le gouvernement a
raison de voile aller vite sur ce sujet
fondamental pour les français il faut
aller vite parce que les français n'en
peuvent plus hausse du prix de l'essence
au ce de manière générale d'ailleurs de
l'énergie on le voit maintenant aux deux
produits alimentaires et certains des
produits de première consommation il
faut réagir et il est heureux que le
gouvernement le fasse après avoir raillé
je crois notre campagne pour la
présidentielle marine le pen on avait
parlé très tôt mais seulement il faut le
faire de manière sérieuse pas seulement
de manière électoraliste vous aurez
remarqué que les chèques peuvent en
général à trois semaines des élections
madame bornes ne doit pas simplement se
contourner contenter d'être la
guichetière j'allais dire à des manuels
macro et devait de faire des chèques je
pense qu'il faut des mesures pérennes
les français ne veulent par ailleurs
gagné les législatives
ils nous ont déjà fait le coup pour la
présidentielle donc ça peut leur
permettre de gagner et je ne sais pas en
tout cas ce sont des vieilles méthodes
éculées je regrette qu'elle soit
toujours appliqué moi je crois pas qu'on
achète les français avec un chèque
essence ou un chèque alimentation je
crois qu'il faut des mesures plus solide
plus concrète vous savez nous on proposé
chaque député du rassemblement national
demain le proposera le portera à
l'assemblée nationale il faut faire
passer la tva sur l'essence de 20% à 5
ennemis et il faut temporairement au
moins une tva à zéro pour cent sur les
biens de ben et son nom cet élément le
shaq alimentation c'est là la
proposition du gouvernement vous
proposez donc cette tva à 0% pour les
100 produits de première nécessité que
vous identifier est-ce que la solution
du gouvernement n'est pas la meilleure
puisque elle va viser des publics ciblés
des publics précaires plus fragiles elle
va durer la priorité vous avez raison
elle va cibler des publics fragiles mais
elle va les cibler une fois c'est à dire
que une fois que vous avez eu votre
chèque consommation qu'est-ce qui se
passe ben rebelote le mois d'après vous
avez à nouveau des problèmes pour
nourrir vos enfants vous avez à nouveau
des problèmes que le chèque alimentation
revient de merveilles
à un bouclier tarifaire jusqu'à la fin
de l'année de mai le gouvernement vous
répondre si je peux vous répondre non la
nôtre et sur l'essence par exemple n'est
pas temporaire sur les produits de
première nécessité que vous répondre on
ne peut pas d'un côté se vanter d'être
les meilleurs en finance le meilleur en
économie dire que on a réduit le chômage
au minimum et en même temps constaté les
bras ballants que aujourd'hui pour
survivre des français ont besoin de
chaque alimentaire quelle régression je
pense qu'il faut prendre des mesures
n'est pas responsable de l'inflation qui
est le gouvernement a augmenté le
gouvernement rend la géopolitique une
sas internationale en a qu'un c'est un
peu ça les gilet jaune je vais pas vous
refaire un cours d'histoire récente le
phénomène avait commencé à cause du prix
de l'essence vous savez en france deux
tiers du prix de l'essence ce sont des
taxes eh bien je crois que le premier à
faire un effort ce devait être le
gouvernement parce qu'on est dans un
paradoxe qui n'est plus acceptée par les
français plus l'essence augmente plus
les tasses enrichis et plus les français
s'appauvrissent donc je crois qu'il faut
maintenant changer ça retrouver un
équilibre sérieux moi je pense à ces
français qui doit faire 50 km le matin
50 km le soir pour aller travailler et
bien quand on a 300 euros d'essence a
payé par semaine et que ça devient 400
avec ça devient 500 ce n'est plus
supportable en main alors en avant les
arts y faire un sur ce sujet c'est une
foire aux éphèbes du provisoire régis
faut enlever de la taxe sur l'essence
c'est la seule solution alors vous
proposer également des hausses de
salaire de 10% mais vous avez
certainement entendu françois asselin le
président la ceppm ce matin qui dit qu'
il n'y aura pas d'augmentation uniforme
des salaires par les entreprises est ce
que du coup votre projet n'est pas caduc
non et d'ailleurs on est plutôt d'accord
avec lui c'est à dire que nous ce que
nous proposons c'est que les entreprises
qui le vol qui le souhaitent et qui
veulent augmentant à augmenter leur
masse salariale en tout cas leurs
salariés de 10% soit exonérée des
charges patronales sur ces 10 % pourquoi
parce qu'on a vu qu'ils avaient décidé
de vous proposer soit vraiment
l'augmentation de 10 des patients dont
21 décès vous perdez jamais dit ça à
ouides hawks et on a toujours été très
clair
on a toujours été très clair sur notre
mesure pourquoi parce que c'est une
mesure qui ne fait de mal à personne et
qui peut faire que du bien ça ne fait
pas de mal à l'état
comme ça fait pas mal à l'état parce
qu'il n'y a pas moins de deux charges
qui rentre ça ne fait pas mal aux
entreprises parce que ce sont celles qui
le décide et ça fait évidemment du bien
aux salariés pourquoi est ce que nous
voulons cette mesure parce que nous on
croit pas à la baguette magique on croit
pas que en tapant sur les entreprises on
créera de l'emploi demain comme le
croient certains
nous on pense que les entreprises qui le
veulent peuvent augmenter les salaires
les entreprises en tension parle souvent
de la restauration du tourisme qui
cherchent des bras et bien pour ça il
faut augmenter les salaires mais si
derrière vous avez l'état qui frappe et
qui dit attention vous venez d'augmenter
de 10 euros eh bien nous on va vous
reprendre 10 euros supplémentaires
forcément les patrons recule donc cette
mesure elle est sage elle prend en
compte les équilibres écolo économique
et surtout elle ne tape pas une fois
encore sur la tête des pme et tpe qui
n'en peuvent plus c'est une solution et
ce sera une bonne situation pour tous il
faut quand même bien le préciser mais
nous avons toujours été très ouvert lui
ça doit être conditionné c'est à dire
que des aides qui ont été donnés pendant
la crise sanitaire beaucoup
d'entreprises ont été aidées est ce
qu'elles doivent pas aujourd'hui à leur
tour mettre la main au portefeuille vous
savez beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont été
aidées pendant la crise sanitaire et
très honnêtement il faut reconnaître que
là le gouvernement sur cette partie là
précisément a fait le boulot aujourd'hui
elle se retrouvant la situation de se
demander comment elles vont rembourser
nous nous avions fait une proposition
qui était sage c'est est de transformer
cette date en en font preuve pour faire
simple c'est à dire pour recapitaliser
les entreprises mais vous savez beaucoup
d'entreprises voient le mur de la dette
se rapprocher à vitesse grand v donc ces
mesures-là qui était hier utile vont
demain demander beaucoup de vigilance
pour que le nombre de faillites ne
croise pas de manière non sans effacer
la dette des entreprises il faut en tout
cas imaginer un système c'est ce que
nous proposons de faire en sorte que
cette dette soit réintégrée dans les
fonds propres parce que renault soit
mais tu viens
oui mais je pense que pour les tpe et
pme il faut généraliser la mesure autre
proposition du présent la ceppm ce matin
c'est d'étaler la prime macron pour que
les entreprises puissent la verse et que
ça ne pèse pas trop sur leur trésorerie
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est une
bonne idée
tout ce qui va dans le sens d'un
allègement des conditions de trésorerie
des entreprises va dans le bon sens
voilà mais vous me parliez tout à
l'heure du de la prime macron vous
validez ça peut permettre à plus de
bénéficiaires de l'obtenir tout ce qui
va dans le sens de la valorisation du
travail et de l'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat sont pour autant asphyxier les
entreprises va dans le bons donc vous
n'en avez pas qu'elle soit obligatoire
non une fois encore il y à des
entreprises qui ne pourraient pas se le
permettre pour lesquelles ce serait la
chronique d'une mort annoncée je pense
que dans la situation de turbulences
dans laquelle nous sommes nous devons
protéger chaque tpe et chaque pme comme
un joyau
pardon oui aude les loyers mesure le
blocage des loyers qui est donc sur la
table du gouvernement c'est ce que
propose plusieurs associations de
locataires et elisabeth bornes la
première ministre a estimé elle que
c'est une fausse bonne idée car il ya de
nombreux propriétaires qui sont de
petits retraités qui ont des petites
retraites en tout cas qu est ce que vous
vous en pensez je pense qu'il faut de la
concertation que ça ne peut pas venir
d'en haut que ça ne peut pas être
imposée parce qu'effectivement c'est la
question du pouvoir d'achat inquiet
derrière on va être clair est qui et qui
en découlent de la question de
l'inflation mais des gens aujourd'hui
ont du mal déjà se nourrir nous payer un
loyer siens allemagne c'est un problème
mais dans le même temps vous l'avez dit
ces loyers parfois sont un complément de
retraite pour des gens qui sans cela
toucherait 600 700 euros de retraite et
qu'ils ne pourraient pas vivre si on
gelait l'augmentation des loyers dont je
pense qu'il faut de la concertation
quand on ne peut pas comme le fait
madame bord par exemple trouver une
solution médiane de plafonnement plus
pourquoi pas bien sûr gars bien sûr
plafonnement serait probablement une
bonne idée le fer avec les associations
de locataires mais aussi avec les
bailleurs parce qu'il n'ya pas que des
grands propriétaires qui louent leurs
locaux ou leur appartement il y a aussi
des petits propriétaires pour qui
c'était la poire pour la soif pendant
qu'il ils ont travaillé ils ont connu
maison enfin que l' indice de révision
des loyers est axée sur l'inflation peut
le dire et donc se réjouir c'est un peu
ça a beaucoup augmenté logiquement les
mettez vous dans la place d'un retraité
qui va avoir à l'inflation qui va devoir
payer sur les chances son essence plus
cher les fruits et les légumes plus cher
si de l'autre côté une de ses sources de
revenus n'augmentent pas eh bien on va
le mettre en précarité donc la précarité
des uns ne peut pas être comblé par la
précarité des autres c'est pour ça qu'il
faut immédiatement ça serait quand même
tout à fait
légalement une voix mais pour ça il faut
pas rejeter du revers de la main toute
solution comme semble l'avoir fait mal à
en parler une dernière mesure sur le
pouvoir d'achat une proposition du
gouvernement c'est le leasing à hauteur
de 100 euros par mois d'enquêté a
proposé par emmanuel macron pour que
tout le monde puisse avoir accès à une
voiture électrique est ce que ça c'est
une bonne idée
comment ce sera appliqué quelles seront
les modalités comment est ce qu'on
pourra y avoir accès je ne comprends pas
pourquoi le gouvernement fait sans
mauvais jeu de mots des usines à gaz
pour tous pourquoi il n'ya que ça n'est
pas parce que vous allez voir que pour
avoir ce leasing ça va pas être si
simple quelle voiture quel est le coût
total de la voiture quand même parce
qu'il faut se poser la question ce
gouvernement est tellement déconnecté
qu'il pense que quand on a une voiture
qui sur le marché de l'occasion vaut
2000 euros qui marche au diesel on peut
du jour au lendemain investir dans une
voiture quand vos quarante mille parce
qu'elle est électrique je pense que la
première
c'est le prix de l'essence sur un mois
c'est même peut-être moins pour beaucoup
de personnes on vous dit qu'elles
prennent la voiture tous les jours oui
peut être mais là mais dax d'avoir accès
à une voiture si ça te dit l'un soyons
pragmatiques si ça peut permettre à
certains d'accéder à une voiture plus
neuf et d'avoir moins de frais d'essence
évidemment qu'on va pas dire non
pour moi en profite ça en est moins sûr
mais une mesure qui aiderait tous les
français seraient hünnebeck ce pardon
une baisse de la tva sur les produits
énergétiques et notamment sur le gasoil
et sur l'essence parce qu'une fois
encore il faut arrêter de faire croire
que les automobilistes sont de dangereux
pollueurs et qu' il est c'est en leur
tapant ont su qu'on fait quand même une
mesure en faveur de la pollution si vous
financez le carburant oui vous savez
aujourd'hui les pv aujourd'hui les
batteries malheureusement sont fabriqués
à l'étranger souvent en chine
si on se retire du nucléaire on va vers
l'éolienne comme ça ensemble prendre le
chemin oui au final la solution n'est
pas forcément très bonne un point ça
vaut entre deux milliards et demi et six
milliards et demi donc ça a un coût très
important si vous baissez à la fois la
tva sur les carburants ainsi que sur les
prix de produits de première nécessité
ça fait un trou important dans les
finances de l'état oui ça fait à peu
près 11 à 12 milliards par an mais mais
il faut encore ça c'est le premier effet
quand vous réduisez la tva effectivement
le premier est fait pour les tasses une
baisse des recettes le deuxième effet
c'est que les gens consomment plus et
que donc ils paieront de la tva sur plus
de produits locaux le déficit est
partiellement comblé et puis une fois
encore depuis plusieurs années où
l'essence est passé au-dessus de 1 75
l'état s'est enrichie sur la tva sur le
dos des automobilistes
la question et qu'at-il fait de cet
argent parce qu'il ay baisse de 18
centimes d'accord d'accord mais là
encore ce sont des mesures temporaires
mais une fois encore 1 600 milliards de
dettes supplémentaires
augmentation le vide un peu plus jamais
d'accord mais augmentation des recettes
de tva sur l'essence où est passé
l'argent celui il ya des zones
d'économies il ya en france beaucoup de
fraudes fiscales et sociales au minimum
au minimum et on a lu un certain nombre
de rapports du sénat qui le disaient au
minimum 40 milliards il faut y aller on
a une immigration qui nous coûte au bas
mot 18 milliards par an voyez les zones
d'économies est lé exhaustive alors mais
plutôt que de tondre les français qui
payent leur essence pour aller
travailler alors parmi d'autres
des retraites il y aura pas de
concertation avant septembre a dit le
gouvernement et je peux vous trouvez
c'est un abandon en rase campagne oui
mais vous savez ce gouvernement est
déterminé à faire passer la retraite à
65 ans non pas parce que c'est une
opportunité non pas parce que c'est une
mesure de bon sens mais parce que c'est
idéologique vous avez j'imagine comme
moi lui les rapports du comité
d'orientation des retraites moi je les
lis toujours avec beaucoup d'attention
parce que le gouvernement s'y réfèrent
souvent eh bien ces mêmes rapports nous
disent que
passez 2030 avant le milieu des années
2030 les caisses de retraite dans la
situation actuelle seront à nouveau en
équilibre est ce qu'on va mettre un coup
de poignard dans ce système auquel les
français tiennent tant pour quelques
années difficiles vous savez un
seulement pour ça le gouvernement dit
qu'il veut la relance et la protection
sociale et notamment la dépendance notre
modèle social donc l'argent des
retraites aussi servir à cela mais une
partie moi j'aime expliquer quelque
chose aujourd'hui un français sur deux
lorsqu'ils arrivent à l'âge de la
retraite et soient chômeurs soit en
invalidité ai donc décaler l'âge de la
retraite c'est faire que au lieu de
rester trois ans chômeur il restera
quatre cinq ou six ans au lieu de rester
deux ou trois ans en invalidité il
restera quatre cinq ou six ans et donc
vous allez pour un temps très court
améliorer la situation des caisses de
retraite mais vous allez aggraver le
déficit des caisses chômage et des gants
la réforme il n'y a pas que la nage à 65
ans il ya aussi de tenir compte des
pénibilités partir à 60 ans pour ceux
qui ont des carrières très longue oui
bien sûr les deux en fait il faudra fait
nos calculs mélanger mais vu les données
que je viens de vous deux énoncés ça
veut dire en moyenne pour l'ensemble des
français une baisse des pensions de 10 %
puisque plus rares seront ceux qui
arriveront à taux plein à la retraite à
65 ans mais vous savez moi je veux bien
même imaginons que le gouvernement a
raison allez je vous concède ça est-ce
qu'on est obligé de voir la question de
nos anciens avec une calculette et un
boulier seulement est-ce qu'on peut pas
se dire que tous ceux qui ont travaillé
pour la nation qui ont enrichi notre
pays qui ont permis de créer l'économie
ne mérite pas après 60 ans ou 62 ans de
vivre une retraite en bonne santé en
profitant des leurs et en profitant de
leur loue alors enlevé d'excusés entre
landivisiau envie de plus en plus
longtemps pas toujours en bonne santé
mais il a parlé de la population et
porter la population qui peut travailler
plus longtemps sans dommage
en termes de santé donc très bien mais
usagers aient envie de plus en plus
longtemps je vous le répète avoir une
retraite à 60 ans pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 20 ans puis
progressivement jusqu'à 62 ans ça permet
de vivre heureux à la retraite ça permet
de ne pas alourdir les dettes des
caisses sociales et de sécurité sociale
volet santé et ça permet aussi de vivre
le rapport ils se basent quand même sur
la réforme touraine et sur le décalage
de l'âge de la retraite vous aussi vous
prévoyez de partir en majorité à 60 ans
ou 62 ans est bien de fait vous allez à
alourdir le média milliards de milliards
c'est quand même pas rien c'est pas rien
jusqu'au milieu des années 2030 vous
avez raison mais après c'est tout à fait
absorbable mais une fois encore c'est 9
milliards vous allez gagner ailleurs je
le répète quand on arrive à 65 ans à la
retraite mais que depuis l'âge de 55 ans
on est au chômage puis au rsa aller
mieux depuis le début de l'émission a
déjà dépensé plus de 20 milliards en
fait vous écoutez je vous dis ce qu'a
dit elisabeth bornes dans les jets
composé mois des économies
elle a dit qu annoncé aux français
qu'ils vont travailler - brandir la
retraite à 60 ans c'est leur mentir
c'est ce qu'a fait le rn pendant des
années alors répondez à elisabeth borne
est ce que vous avez menti aux français
pendant des années non c'est elle qui
nous manque c'est elle que qui nous
montrent disant que si on ne réforme pas
le système le système va s'effondrer je
vous le répète je crois vous l'avoir
prouvé c'est faux pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
tiennent tant à cette retraite à 65 ans
d'abord parce qu'ils ont la pression de
l'union européenne vous savez que contre
un certain nombre d' aide économique et
bien il y avait par exemple à bruxelles
absolument mais c'est d'ailleurs tout à
fait officielle et puis une vision je le
répète idéologique macro nist pour
emmanuel macron nous sommes des
consommateurs producteurs à partir du
moment où on ne consomme pas assez on
produit pas assez on ne compte pas c'est
pour ça qu'ils délaissent la santé c'est
pour ça qu'ils délaissent l'éducation
nationale c'est pour ça qu'ils laissent
les prix aux anciens du gouvernement
alors vous vous proposez la retraite
minimale à 1000 euros on est bien
d'accord est-ce que compte tenu de
l'inflation vous vous dit tiens il
faudrait peut-être la relever ce qu'il
faudrait relever ce seuil de 1000 euros
il vous aura pas échappé aussi dans
notre programme que nous étions pour la
taxation des retraites sur l'inflation
donc évidemment si l'autre est minimale
si nous pouvons mettre en place lorsque
nous serons élus à l'assemblée n'allez
que nous aurons beaucoup de députés ce
système si le gouvernement accepte que
nous le faisions pas de façon passé nous
revalorisons les choses mais vous savez
nous on veut pas faire comme monsieur
mélenchon sera combien votre retraite
minimale ça dépend de l'inflation nous
le verrons bien comprendre 100 euros
jean luc mélenchon le niveau du smic
pour l'instant nous raison c'est un peu
chiche aimer c'est chiche mais
raisonnable et c'est honnête c'est par
réseau nas qui oppose emmanuel macron
dans les petites secondes sans abri qui
les anime et avec tout les a imités et
je voulais expliquer tout à l'heure
pratiquement plus personne n'arrivera
avec ses annuités complète si on passe
la retraite à 65 ans une fois encore
mais vous savez je crois que les
français sont pas dupes les belles
promesses des manuels macron n'engagent
que ceux qui les croient comme disait je
crois charles pasqua en tout cas
n'engage que lui-même les français en
ont assez soupé de sa politique pourquoi
y aller de ses parents il ya des
promesses et puis il ya des réalisations
oui effectivement le plein emploi est à
portée de main a dit ce matin donc
elisabeth bornand de sa passation de
pouvoir avec olivier du soft est ce que
vous y croyez
est-ce que vous saluer aussi la
politique qui a eu lors de ce
quinquennat et qui a eu pour effet de
faire quand même très sensiblement
reculer le chômage oui et créer 400
milles pauvres créé un nombre de
français que mal logés qui ne cesse de
croître oui effectivement aujourd'hui il
ya des gens qui s'étaient pas les noms
sur le chômage en revanche permet de
terminer ma phrase je conteste le modèle
qui est qu'aujourd'hui on peut
travailler et ne pas pouvoir se loger
voilà aujourd'hui on doit vivre
dignement de son travail je pense que la
valeur travail doivent être remises au
centre de notre politique économique
vous savez c'est à long terme qu'il faut
y réfléchir c'est à long terme si on
continue dans cette mondialisation
échevelé si on continue de faire en
sorte que au sein même de l'union
européenne nous financions notre propre
concurrence que nous acceptions avec des
traités de libre échange que des
produits arrivent du bout du monde en ne
respectant pas les mêmes normes que
celles qu'on impose à nos entreprises
avec des prix cinq fois inférieurs et
bien nous allons tuer les entreprises
françaises et donc il faut réfléchir non
pas pour l'heure non pas pour les
prochaines législatives seulement il
faut réfléchir à long terme ce n'est pas
ce que fait emmanuel macron son modèle
économique n'est pas compatible avec le
plein emploi et puis vous savez quand on
n'y croyait pas le plein emploi
je vais vous dire franchement la plus
grande gloire ce serait de revenir vous
voir dans cinq ans et vous dire je me
suis trompé mais je n'y crois pas je ne
crois pas d'abord parce que nos taux de
chômage est quand même très largement
supérieur à beaucoup de nos voisins
peuplement que ça il a baissé c'est vrai
mais nous sommes toujours à 5,3 je crois
pourquoi parce que il y à des chômeurs
qui ont été changé de catégorie donc ces
tours de passe passe ne trompe pas c'est
une illusion pour vous s'il a présenté
les chômeurs dits a changé a vraiment
moins de chômeurs aujourd'hui je le dis
mais pas de manière aussi significative
que le dit la propagande du gouvernement
et surtout pas de manière pérenne il
croyait bien je le regrette si nous ne
changeons pas les fondamentaux de
l'économie macro nist vous avez parlé de
valeur travail à l'instant pour arriver
à ce résultat du plein emploi en 2027 le
gouvernement mise notamment sur une
réforme du rsa une nouvelle couche de
réforme sur l'assurance chômage
est-ce que ça eh ben ça va dans le bon
sens à ce que ça va dans le sens de la
reconnaissance de la valeur travail non
c'est brad et le travail voilà quand on
dit que en face du rsa il va falloir
travailler un certain nombre d'heures
ont fait que aujourd'hui le travail peut
être rémunéré à 6 euros de l'heure voilà
quand on appelle à une immigration
massive pour faire les travaux que
soi-disant les français ne seraient pas
capables ou ne voudrais pas faire mais
les agriculteurs ils ont eu bien besoin
même de migration de rire les salaires
par le bas mais vous voyez ce qui
confère la gaillette et ses idoles
seulement ce type de raisonnement tirent
les salaires vers le bas amène une
paupérisation et créer un nouvel
esclavagisme nous ce n'est pas notre
modèle nous nous pensons que quand il ya
plus de cinq millions de chômeurs eh
bien il faut donner envie aux français
d'occuper ses travaux et bien parfois la
pénibilité de certains travaux n'est pas
en phase avec le salaire qui est proposé
est d'où la mesure des 10% de
propositions d'augmentation de salaire
c'est à dire rendre le travail plus
attractif notamment en fonction de la
pénibilité mais si on augmente les
salaires de manière volontaire de la
part des entreprises et si on garantit
une retraite à 60 et 62 ans beaucoup de
ces métiers de pénibles deviendront à
nouveau attractif nous ce que nous
voulons c'est créer de l'emploi pour le
français avant d'imaginer en créer
d'autres merci on va pas reparler va pas
tout à fait autre chose plutôt le
casting de vos candidats à l'aller aux
législatives brégier plusieurs de vos
candidats aux législatives sont fait
remarquer par leur amateurisme j'en
prends pour exemple cette candidate qui
ne sait pas ce que ce sont les services
publics où ce candidat qui montre une
photo de sa femme qui est noir pour
expliquer qu'il est pas raciste est ce
que c'est vraiment respecter les
français que de présenter ce genre de
candidat aux élections législatives
vous savez on peut réussir une émission
de télévision est très mauvais et lui le
président de la république je crois est
un beau parleur et moi je considère que
son quinquennat est un échec falla est
là vous êtes des amateurs c'est ce que
disait le président de la république
mais je vous retourne la question vous
savez quand c'est votre première
télévision oui vous pouvez pris par le
stress vous avez fait votre première
télévision j'imagine que c'est stressant
je suis sûr vous l'avez réussi est ce
que pour autant vous serez amené à
un stress vous pourriez faire d'ailleurs
à peu près la même chose avec des
candidats de tous les partis moi vous
savez j'ai vu des débats ou des
candidats d'autres partis stressait
chercher leurs mots est-ce que c'est
grave alors elle vous l'a laissé
suffisamment formés préparer pour être
candidat aux législatives nous avons
formé préparer pour être député c'est à
dire que nous avons regardé leur
parcours personnel leur parcours
politique
leur parcours humain et nous avons dit
est ce que ses 567 candidat demain s'ils
sont élus pour être de bons députés et à
chaque fois nous avons tiré la
conclusion que oui est-ce qu'ils
pourront être des bon débatteur pour
leur premier débat honnêtement c'est pas
la question on peut avoir raté un débat
et certains ont raté leurs débats et
demain un très bon député parce qu'on
sera sur le terrain parce qu'on est
solide sur ses valeurs et ses
fondamentaux et parce qu'on a la france
au coeur et envie de défendre nos
concitoyens vous voyez moi je pense que
c'est la sincérité qui devrait assurer
la moyenne de recrutement chez vous non
je ne crois pas peut-être suffisamment
attiré deux camps d'idron nous avons de
très bons candidats moi je les assume
croyez moi et sincèrement vous voulez
j'ai vu ce qu'ils ont montré des
faiblesses quand même caractérisée ou
cela un manque de connaissances de
compétences et pendant de connaissances
et les électeurs attendent quand même
qu'on connaisse les dossiers
mais c'est vous mêmes vous travaillez on
voit bien gentil bien bien ce qu'on a vu
là n'ont pas travaillé il nous a dit
qu'il avait beaucoup marqué par dj vous
réponds que je vais vous répondre j'
avais pas parlé de la chance d'être
porte parole du rassemblement national
je fais beaucoup de débats télévision et
j'ai en face de moi souvent de bons
orateurs avec de bons arguments et qui
me disent les yeux dans les yeux nous
allons combattre la politique d'
emmanuel macron je suis l'opposition et
qu'on retrouve le jour d'après candidats
macro nist ou même ministre d'emmanuel
macro moi j'ai débattu avec monsieur
abbas qui m'expliquait qu'il est l
opposition que monsieur macron était le
mal absolu choisissez le nom
complètement par hasard parce que c'est
une prise ou à l'air voilà non
librement en début d'émission donc j'ai
aucun problème avec ça mais gdg débattu
aussi avec des gens de gauche qui se
sont retrouvés à soutenir monsieur
macron est ce que ces gens là même s'ils
ont le verbe est haut même s'ils savent
se tenir sur un plateau sont des gens
disent qu'elles sont des bons et deux
mois je ne crois pas est-ce que c'était
utile d'être présent dans toutes les
circonscriptions oui je le répète je le
répète ce n'est pas un désert elle est
passible et peut-être nous avons ciblé
nous avons ciblé les candidats nos cinq
cent soixante sept candidats sont de
bons candidats ils feront s'ils sont
élus de bons députés est ce qu'ils ont
fait lors de leur première prestation un
bon débat non pour certains est ce que
c'est grave non dernière question sur
jordan bardella et où l'être est-ce que
jordan par des laques et président par
intérim va devenir président pour deux
bons du rassemblement national et à ce
moment là quand écoutez il faut que vous
posiez la question à deux personnes
votre avis
votre avis nous on a la chance
incroyable d'avoir une figure
emblématique qui s'appelle marine le pen
est un très bon président de parti qui
s'appelle jordan bardella donc quoi
qu'il arrive ce sera
botté en touche je botte pas en touche
je voterai non alors on a annoncé que
marine le pen est ce que ne reprendrait
pas forcément les rênes du parti alors
est-ce que si marine le pen souhaite
reprendre les rênes du parti nous serons
heureux oui est-ce que jordan bardella a
la capacité d'être un très bon président
de parti la réponse est oui est ce que
ça vous semblerait bon pour l'avenir du
parti pour marine le pen qui pourrait se
consacrer à peut-être une prochaine
présidentielle qu'il devienne le patron
du parti mais je laisserai la rentrée
dit vous ne répondrai pas non ici
attendez moi la fin de la phrase séveno
dit la même chose non on peut avoir deux
talents 1 qui gère le parti est acquis
la figure politique ce serait je crois
mais ce genre de bonne chère peut
assurer la relève si marine le pen n'est
pas candidate à la prochaine élection
présidentielle voilà on est on est on
est vraiment loin il en a les capacités
j'ordonne bardella je crois qu'il l'a
montré il a la capacité politique il a
la capacité de gestion il a la capacité
humaine il a je crois un fort pouvoir
charismatique jordan bavella a toutes
les qualités requises pour être un bon
président park est ce que j'en ai
la présidentielle je crois qu'il ferait
un excellent candidat
quand je ne sais pas il serait un
excellent candidat eh ben c'est une
déclaration qu'on retiendra merci
brégier c'est mon avis merci dame
j'ordonne bardella candidat à la
présidentielle ça vous irait tout à fait
il le pen ou si gg oui non mais ça on a
compris même si j'aurais été vous avez
été sans porte parole tiens un mot on
voulait aussi vous interrogez mais je
vais le faire eric zemmour c'est une
claque pour vous s'il est devant vous à
saint tropez il est compté dans la 4e
circonscription du vin dont je ne crois
pas qu'il sera élu mais s'il jamais il
l'était celui verdict des urnes donc ça
peut pas être une claque en soi
vous savez je sais que vous allez me
poser la question des alliances nous
n'avons pas choisi de faire alliance
avec reconquête parce que nous avons
déjà un certain nombre de divergences
sur des points programmatiques et puis
que une fois encore les conglomérats
contre nature je crois que c'est pas bon
on l'a vu avec ce que fait monsieur
mélenchon et un certain nombre d'autres
partis de gauche qui se trouve obligé
alors qu'ils sont républicains et
laïques de faire partie de s'asseoir à
la même table que des gens qui veulent
le burqini dans les piscines qui sont
d'accord pour des réunions interdites
aux blancs tout cela n'est pas très
raisonnable et ya un premier tour on
choisit au deuxième tour on élimine et
on verra bien ce qu alors s'il est élu
et que vous l'êtes aussi vous aurez
peut-être un parti à l'assemblée il
pourrait venir dans le parti ce sera son
choix langres où pardon je n'en locaux
de l'assemblée nationale on n'est même
plus que vous l'acceptiez on n'est même
plus dans la politique fiction dit dans
la science fiction je ne vois pas eric
zemmour accepté dans l'est dans un
groupe tenu par un parti politique qu'il
estime lui-même comme étant une vieille
boutique dont vous débarrassant
la grâce et demande à être assiégé vos
côtés on s'appelle rassemblement donc
s'il est touché par la grâce pourquoi
pas vous me voyez très dubitatif yves
thréard s'est installé en face de vous
bonsoir m'en faire et
la rédaction du figaro c'est à vous
alors on va faire un peu de politique on
va on ne fait que ça d'ailleurs un
campagne présidentielle qui a
probablement été la meilleure si on en
croit le résultat de madame le pen
depuis trois fois qu'elle se présente
est omniprésente justement dans les
médias avec la volonté de gagner
contrairement à son père qui dont on
pouvait douter à l'époque s'ils
voulaient vraiment gagner cette élection
et puis là il ya des élections
législatives et ils sont où les
candidats assemblement nationale sur le
terrain c'est tout on ne vous entend pas
on voit on écoute madame le pen qui a
des ambitions qui paraissent
très très très très faible et qui dit
toutefois hier macro ont gagné donc
voilà cette fois la stratégie je me sens
très inquiet je vais vous rassurer
d'abord marine le pen fait beaucoup
d'interviews dans les télévisions et
dans les radios elle fait une campagne
de terrain soutenir nos candidats est en
ce moment même dans les bouches du rhône
pour soutenir nos candidats tous nos
candidats font une campagne de terrain
jordan dardel a lui aussi va expliquer
notre vision stratégique sur les
plateaux notre ambition est très clair
avoir le maximum de députés à
l'assemblée nationale première une
indication tournage 150 circonscriptions
je crois ou marine le pen est arrivé en
tête ouais bon et dont on va se battre
pour les avoir
maintenant ce que nous ne voulons pas
faire parce que nous voulons être
honnête avec les électeurs qui ont un
peu marre je crois des fausses promesses
c'est de faire comme monsieur mélenchon
dire eh bien nous aurons la majorité
absolue et je serai premier ministre
personne n'y croit pas lui-même il est
même pas il est même pas candidat claude
non un cloud c'est drôle
je crois que monsieur mélenchon n'est
pas drôle non je crois pas non non non
je pense que il est aujourd'hui un vrai
danger pour notre république et qu'il
est dangereux 1 vous la démocratie ou
pour la france pour la france pour la
démocratie pour la république et pour la
laïcité vous savez moi je vois jean luc
mélenchon comme un homme qui à tour
unique et sans foi ni loi et qui est
prêt à vendre son âme pour des électeurs
on le voit on le voit dans sa course
effrénée au vote communautariste on le
voit quand ils essayent de nous
expliquer que voilées la femme est un
progrès pour le monde on le voit quand
il excuse tout et n'importe quoi pour
aller ratisser le plus large possible
cet homme a perdu son arme aujourd'hui
ils cherchent une voie de sortie et nous
annonce qu'il sera premier ministre il
ne le sera pas ce sera probablement pour
lui l'occasion de tirer sa révérence
politique honnêtement tout cela n'est
pas sérieux je crois que je préférais le
sénateur à barbiche quand il était
sénateur et qu'il répétait du matin au
soir assimilation république et laïcité
lui au moins je le respectais donc c'est
quelqu'un qui se place dans le
séparatisme rapport jeni semer le
racialisme le séparatisme c'est jean luc
mélenchon aujourd'hui c'est jean luc
mélenchon vous savez moi un homme qui
veut désarmer la police qui nous
présente nos forces de l'ordre comme des
gens étant raciste qui applaudit quand
autour de lui on crie tout le monde
déteste la police cet homme là n'a pas
la stature d'un homme d'état une fois
encore c'est anti français
si en tout cas un discours incompatible
avec ce qu'est la france à défaut à
défaut par dont il a eu des électeurs
mais beaucoup je vous avez bien remarqué
que je fais la différence est que je
parle de jean luc mélenchon que je ne
parle pas de ses électeurs mais je crois
que beaucoup vont se sentir trahi en
l'écoutant se sentir trahi aussi par
cette espèce d'alliance parce que il y a
deux dents des gens peu fréquentables
quand même un des gens je le répète
encore mais qui font des réunions
interdites aux blancs je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup d'électeurs qui ne se
reconnaissent pas vous reconnaissez
quand même qu'il a des électeurs qu'ils
peuvent aussi voter pour vous sur vidas
man lorsque justement pourquoi dans le
cadre de cette campagne électorale
puisque vous avez vu et c'était pas
prévu que jean luc mélenchon talonne
marine le pen à l'élection
présidentielle
comment vous faites justement pour
essayer dé séduire ces électeurs là et
le faire en sorte qu'ils viennent vers
vous à l'occasion de ces élections
législatives nous lors c'est quoi votre
le leitmotiv de ces élections pour vous
c'est quoi le pouvoir d'achat n'a parlé
tout à l'heure de certain nombre de
mesures nous pensons que c'est l'urgence
absolue absolue deuxièmement faire
barrage à emmanuel macron voilà parce
qu'on pense que cinq ans supplémentaires
la france ne s'en remettrait pas et nous
allons expliquer et c'est pour ça que
nous sommes beaucoup sur le terrain à
tous les électeurs que la seule voie
raisonnable et de bon sens contraire
manuel macron celle rassemblement
national qui peut croire vous gagnez pas
les élections légistatives comment vous
pouvez me croire qui peut croire que
jean luc mélenchon qui le vendredi appel
à voter de manière déguisée mais
personne n'est dupe emmanuel macron le
lundi suivant appelle les français à
descendre dans la rue pour lutter contre
la politique d' emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron je le disais tout à l'heure qui
lui a renvoyé l'ascenseur en nommant
ministre de l'éducation quelqu'un qui
aurait eu sa place à la france insoumise
temps il fait de la race et de la
couleur le centre de sa politique moi je
crois que c'est dangereux et donc il
faut clairement que nous convainquions
nos compatriotes que oui nous sommes une
opposition raisonnable et déterminé
alors ce que je comprends pas c'est
qu'il ya un mot que vous prononcez
jamais alors qu' il serait me
semble-t-il de bon ton si j'étais de
votre côté enfin si ici en étant au
rassemblement national c'est le mot
proportionnelle vous faites un bon score
à l'élection présidentielle et
vous risquez fort en dépit de tout ce
que vous dites d'avoir un nombre de
députés relativement limitée qui ne
correspond pas comme c'était déjà le cas
après la précédente fois à à la force de
frappe que vous avez réalisé que vous
avez montré à l'élection présidentielle
pourquoi vous ne vous battez pas sur ce
terrain là nous battons nous nous
battons les entend pas et je vous
expliquerai peut-être après pourquoi
mais lisez nos professions de foi
regarder ce que nous faisons sur le
terrain nous parlons toujours de vous
demander la proportionnelle intégrale
intégral si possible oui et c'est pour
ça une fois encore que nous voulons le
maximum de députés parce que plus nous
en aurons plus nous aurons une force de
frappe vous savez il ya des gens qui
sont pour la proportionnelle même dans
la mosaïque pro macron il y aura demain
une multitude de groupes à l'assemblée
nationale parce que la macro nice n'est
pas un bloc c'est une dizaine je crois
de formation les nippes ou du ps je sais
pas comment on se prononce c'est aussi
une dizaine de formations et donc la
probabilité que nous ayons un des plus
gros groupes de l'assemblée nationale
n'est pas du tout une hypothèse
impossible et que d'autres groupes nous
rejoindre sur la proportionnelle n'est
pas une hypothèse impossible et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut aller voter le 12 et
19 juin parce que chaque député
rassemblement national amènera avec lui
ce projet là à l'assemblée nationale
mais ça devient une vraie urgence vous
avez raison de le souligner et pourquoi
vous la demande et pas plus de fer sont
plus plus plus insistantes je dirais
est-ce que vous avez vu les chiffres de
décompte de des télévisions et des
radios sur les temps de parole voilà si
sur le service public français deux
tiers du temps de parole est allouée à
monsieur jean luc mélenchon je n'en suis
pas responsable
personne au rassemblement national dont
est responsable permet de dire ça ce
sont les décomptes chiffrés qui sont
publiques que vous pouvez aller
constater vous même le pire est en
france inter où là on atteint des
chiffres
en tout cas c'est une radio qui donne à
la gauche une part d'antenne à peu près
trois à quatre fois supérieur à ses
scores électoraux oui
voilà la vraie raison elles n'ont dans
la vraie raison aujourd'hui que le
service public malheureusement ne
remplit plus toujours sa mission que
healy a derrière une redevance et que
des entreprises privées avec mission
vous êtes d'accord avec le président
d'albi qui veut supprimer la redevance
eux visuel sur sa wii mais je regrette
nos regrets tant qu'ils ne veuillent pas
privatiser le service public parce qu'il
va bien falloir continuer à le financer
quand même donc si c'est pas la
redevance qu'est-ce qui va payer c'est
l'impôt et donc au final les classes
moyennes encore elle qui vont payer à
nouveau un peu plus on peut peut-être
rappeler le compte est quand même si
jean luc mélenchon effectivement
occupent les plateaux comme vous dites
c'est aussi parce qu'il a une actualité
c'est aussi parce que il l'a fait il a
réussi cette union de la gauche la nuque
sont donc marine le pen parle en
vacances et en plus elle n'a pas réussi
à faire l'union des droites elle a même
pas essayé alors d'abord il ya plein de
choses dans votre question donc j'ai
mûri je vous réponde rapidement mais
laissez moi vous présenter les choses
dans l'ordre d'abord marine le pen est
parti en vacances à arrêter avec ça les
partis quatre jours se reposer après une
présidentielle où elle avait tout donné
en temps peu
de temps un certain nombre de rendez
vous médiatique vous savez on a vécu la
même chose c'est pour ça qu'on est très
calme et très serein quand on nous a
présenté eric zemmour et vous n'étiez
pas le dernier comme le sauveur du
compatriote et le camp de la droite dont
je ne dis pas moi faire partie il été
surexposés une manière médiatique
incroyable on allumait la télé c'était
et moore ou alors nous nous étions
invités pour parler de zemmour au final
la réalité s'est imposé zemmour en
france c'est 7% et l'enfance elle met un
destin et moi ce sera la même chose il
ya une bulle mélenchon qui va exploser
qui va d'ailleurs explosé parce que sur
le terrain il y à un certain nombre de
candidats dissidents de gauche qui
n'accepte pas la ligne éditoriale je
dirais de jean luc mélenchon est ligne
politique et qui ne se reconnaissent pas
dans cet individu et qui donc vont
proposer des candidatures alternatives
qu'est ce qui vous distingue deux eric
zemmour
le fond et la forme le fond nous
parlions tout à l'heure de la réforme
des retraites avant vous n'arriviez
c'est une différence majeure entre lui
jean-luc mélenchon
kellogg
là dessus parce qu'ils sont chacun ils
ont été chacun à tour de rôle les
poulains des médias mais eric zemmour à
des phrases trop dur trop tranchées au
moment où la france est divisée on est
malade de cette division et une fois là
rassemblés je sais même pas s'il est à
droite je sais pas où il est mais il est
trop en tout cas ça c'est sûr le
changement de prénom ça ne sert à rien
ça stigmatise pour employer un terme
plutôt chère à la gauche mais ça ne sert
à rien les propositions qu'il fait là
remis gracieux c'est une caricature
d'une politique migratoire raisonnable
et qui fait fuir les électeurs plutôt
que de les attirer et puis enfin cette
union des groies des droites c'est quoi
c'est faire l'union avec des gens de l
air qui ne rêve que d'une chose c'est
d'avoir un marocain avec monsieur macron
sait faire l'union avec des gens qui
veulent toujours plus de
décaler l'âge de la retraite toujours
moins de solidarité nationale ça ne nous
ressemble pas nous on veut faire l'union
avec tous les patriotes et j'ai
peut-être vous étonner il ya aussi des
patriotes à gauche alors comment
expliquez-vous que justement le party
les républicains qui en bien piètre état
il n'y a pas plus de deux députés d'élus
qui vous rejoignent ils ont préféré
aller chez zemmour d'ailleurs pas
beaucoup entre nous les combien combien
chez moi aujourd'hui quelques-uns en
tous les cas un oui voila moi ce que je
vois c'est que les républicains c'est
devenu non pas un parti de d'idées mais
c'est un parti de notables qui et se
maintient pour se re faire élire et dans
les élections législatives ils ont
l'impression que le mode de scrutin et
c'est vrai certaines ancrage territorial
vont les sauver d'autres plus
circonspect par rapport à l'état de
leurs partis sont allés se vendre avec
pertes et profits à emmanuel macron et
bien c'est pas grave c'est pas grave
s'ils ne viennent pas nous nous aurons
nos propres députés et nous défendrons
les français à l'assemblée nationale
alors on sait vous avez des problèmes
financiers vous avez été obligé
d'ailleurs de déménager le siège du
parti vous êtes
exposés à des poursuites judiciaires
au niveau européen
est ce que vous comptez sur ces
élections là pour vous refaire une santé
financière c'est pas du tout début des
élections va être très clair le but de
ces ce qui est quand même le cas de
beaucoup de partis qui il faut expliquer
voix voilà le financier d'épargné
rémunéré si j'ai le financement des
partis politiques est lié au nombre de
voix obtenues au premier tour de
législatives et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
parfois dix douze candidats par
circonscription parce que c'est le
financement des partis politiques ses
portes pourquoi vous mettez des
candidats partout même c'est quand vous
avez un peu de leur côté n'ont d'abord
je veux vous êtes des dieux c'est bien
ça peut être une qualité mais je vous ai
déjà répondu sur ce point tri c'est par
où commencer mais je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ce que vous dites non
notre ambition et notre objectif c'est
d'avoir le maximum de députés possible
pour permettre de conduire une politique
le plus proche possible de nos idées et
surtout pour faire barrage jour et nuit
à l'assemblée et sur le terrain à
emmanuel macron c'est ça qui nous anime
tout le temps toujours et partout alors
il ya une chose qu'on a pas bien
comprise c'est marine le pen qui avait
dit dans le figaro il ya quelques
semaines qu'elle ne se représenterait
pas à la prochaine échéance
présidentielle
et puis elle est revenue en arrière
récemment sur un plateau de télévision
et elle est revenue à la charge d'une
certaine façon dans le figaro ou
récemment elle a répondu que sauf
circonstances exceptionnelles elle ne se
c'est la dernière question après s'il en
est presque 13 millions et demi
d'électeurs je crois une confiance
maintenant dans le programme est dans la
personne de marine le pen une capacité à
gouverner qui lui est reconnue elle a
toute légitimité
d'être à nouveau candidate si elle le
souhaite mais c'est un choix personnel
c'est un choix qui est dictée par la
propre gestion de sa vie j'allais dire
mais par aussi les circonstances
nationales et c'est pour ça qu'elle
prendra sa décision à 38 cents oui
moi j'ai l'impression mais vraiment
personnel aujourd'hui que effectivement
l'hypothèse serait qu' elles prennent un
peu de champ mais qu'elle demeure très
active dans la vie politique mais je
connais son engagement je connais son
amour des français et que je sais aussi
très bien que si un jour elle sans qu'
elle peut être utile à la france à la
république elle le fera et c'est vous un
conseil à lui donner vous lui diriez
vas-y retourne je lui dirai pas de
prendre de décision trop tôt et de
regarder comment ça évolue la france a
besoin d'elle sinon vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure que jordan bardella
quoique très jeune et c'est un travail
chez d'autres candidats l'enjeu de
propos d'un autre en tout cas dans votre
partie de bardella du talent on vous
l'assuré bien la faire merci bouleverser
notre invité merci mr r bonne que même
sa semaine prochaine bien sûr auditions
publiques à 19h30 sur un cp et public
sénat il sera présenté par brigitte
boucher bonne semaine à tous et bonne
soirée
[Musique]